hi everyone welcome to our homeroom live
stream sal here from khan academy really
excited about the conversation we're
about to have with david banks who is
really one of the leading educators in
the country uh president of the eagle
academy foundation but before we get
into that i will make my standard
announcements a reminder to everyone
that khan academy is a not-for-profit
organization we can only exist through
philanthropic donations so if you're in
a position to do so please think about
going to khan academy.org donate and
donations of all size make a difference
i also want to give a special shout out
to several organizations that have
helped us over the last
few months really some of these well
before that many years uh longtime
supporters but when they saw that we
were already running at a deficit
precovid and that deficit only increased
because our costs increased because we
obviously our server costs have gone up
two to three x of normal we're trying to
accelerate a whole series of programs
and content so special thanks to bank of
america google.org att fastly novartis
and many others
in helping us close this gap as we are
trying to step up in any way we can to
get the country and actually the world
through
distance learning and actually get to a
place where uh personalized education
and learning not being bound by time or
space becomes a norm not an exception
so with that i'm really excited to
introduce david uh hi david good good
good to see you uh president ceo of the
eagle academy foundation
good to see you as well khan south south
appreciate it
so so david maybe a good place to start
is tell us
what is the eagle academy and why
have you put so much energy into this
so so the eagle academy is a network of
all boys
public schools in new york city
where we work with young men of color
from grades six to grade 12.
um we've got a school in every borough
in new york city as well as one in
newark new jersey so as we sit here
today we've got 3 000 young men across
our schools and have graduated about 2
000 young men over the years and sent
them on to colleges and universities
across the country
we started in collaboration with 100
black men uh in new york uh really as a
response to the national crisis that we
have seen so many of our young men have
faced where they've not graduated from
high school or not presenting themselves
for opportunities in industry i'm
getting caught up in the the uh you know
getting incarcerated caught up in the
criminal justice system all the things
that we hear about on a regular basis
um but there's really been relatively uh
little response to that crisis and so
the eagle academy was created really in
many ways as a response to giving young
men a place where they can hope and
dream and and reach their their full
potential
and there's at least two really
interesting things that might be
surprising for some folks that you just
mentioned
this isn't your traditional
charter school these are actual public
schools in the new york city public
school system i guess in newark in one
case as well and then the other
surprising thing is you don't hear a lot
about you know single sex schools
anymore this is a school for uh young
men at risk young men
how first of all how does the first
thing work what if how does a branded
system of schools within the public
school system work and why did you make
that decision and then why the decision
to focus only on young men
well many years ago when uh when mike
bloomberg was the mayor of new york city
uh he cast a wide net in terms of trying
to get other not-for-profits and
organizations to get more involved in
the public education system and in doing
so um we became part of the 21st century
uh uh education reform effort that was
happening in new york sponsored by the
gates foundation um where they said
listen this is a huge system and we need
uh we need others to get involved and so
that's when our organization 100 black
men decided to get involved over the
years it had become politically
incorrect to have single gender schools
um but but we leaned into that space
really to say you know what is it that
causes young men
to believe in themselves and and to
focus on their own potential and i was
the principal of the school we created
it in the bronx with a group of ninth
grade boys and quickly realized that if
we were gonna do this well we needed to
start earlier than the ninth grade and
our model soon after became a grade six
through twelve model
but we we were intentional in saying
that we wanted it to be traditional
public schools because philosophically
we really felt as though
you can't charter your way out of this
educational arrest charters ought to be
a big part of the response in education
but over 90 percent of high school kids
in america still want a regular
traditional schools like most of us went
to and if you can't move the needle in
that space you're just playing around on
the margins and so we wanted to be able
to lean into that space and that's what
we've done
and what what does it look like what's
different about an eagle academy public
school other than the single gender
focus
what are y'all doing that you think is
different and what have you learned that
has been particularly effective
several things um it's it's about the
culture that you established that says
to young men that we deeply believe in
you and and that may seem like something
really simple um but but it is not you
have to remember that
eighty percent of teachers across
america are white and female
um and don't necessarily have
a background in it or training
and how to work with boys first of all
there's some significant differences
between the energy that boys can bring
to the classroom and that girls we can
bring to the classroom broadly
but when you start talking about um boys
of color
there are some unique challenges um
that those young men bring to the
classroom every day and there's a unique
energy that they bring and very often uh
so the boys find themselves getting
disciplined in school
are being called out for things um that
are really not bad behavior
it's it's it's just having teachers
having a level of sensitivity and
understanding
who the boys are what their backgrounds
are and and and recognizing that there's
a certain way as adults that we have to
show up if we want to get the most out
of these young men so we engage them in
all kinds of professional development
and training for our teachers around
what does it mean uh to meet the boys
where they are we've got
expanded day programming um that really
is about what are the things that boys
are really interested in right um we've
got game rooms you think about it the
boys love to play video games um
but yet in schools uh we we we don't
often
utilize the kinds of things that boys
are interested in we use a one size fits
all kind of approach boys love to
compete
but they don't like to compete
one-on-one they want to compete my group
against your group so how do you how do
you frame a spirit of competition
uh in into how you do your day-to-day
interactions in school but one of the
most important things that we do is it's
just about the culture of
saying to young men we see you we
recognize all of the challenges that you
face on a daily basis we have a daily
town hall meeting for half an hour
before the young men set foot into a
classroom
we we we we pour libation and they get a
chance just to reflect on what's
happening in their lives and the trauma
that so many of them are feeling each
and every day um that's not the kind of
thing that you can measure in a
standardized test but it's the kind of
thing that says to the young men um we
see you
and we're here for you and it makes all
the difference in the world
i can imagine that's very powerful and i
want to encourage everyone watching to
put questions on facebook and youtube
about really anything regarding
education it could be a single gender
education it could be you know this
question around
public schools charter schools it could
be how we're going to do distance
learning and we'll talk a little bit
more about that uh but david as you've
gone on this journey i guess how many
first of all how many years has it been
and what has been kind of your maybe
some of your things you've been
struggling the most with that you're
still trying to figure out and then what
have been some of the the big wins that
you're like wow that's a powerful data
point that shows that we're on the right
track
well there are a few things uh sal i
would tell you that first of all i've
been in education for over 30 years
myself having been a teacher and
assistant principal founding principal
not only the eagle academy but of a
wonderful co-ed school in the bronx as
well so this is a space that i've
dedicated my life to um there are a
number of things that we have learned in
the space for boys but we've also seen
very broadly really for boys and and for
girls um
internationally there have been some
studies that have been done around boys
and and the biggest thing that emerges
is that boys disconnect from school
because school is boring
the connection to what they're doing in
class to what their real interests are
very often are not aligned
and most teachers will tell you that
they recognize that but they struggle
with how to figure out how to how to
make that connection
um so intuitively they know that boys
check out easily um but you've got to
figure out how do you make your lessons
more fast-paced more engaging um in
order for boys to really stay focused
and they've got to be relevant you've
got to be talking about issues that
really do make a difference and that's
where i think we begin to see the
overlap between boys and girls
i'm a firm believer after having spent
three decades in this space
that we're doing education
um the wrong way uh if we really want
everybody to win
and what i mean by that sal is that
we got to reimagine we've got to
recreate
how we are
doing the education experience
right and so what i mean by that is that
you've got
i think we do a really good job of
schooling but not necessarily such a
great job of educating and there's a
difference
right there's a there's the routine of
going to school every day but when you
think about the fact that in new york
city if somebody sends me their child at
pre-k and i have them all the way
through 12th grade that means i've had
them for 14 years
and in new york city if you had a child
for 14 years we've taxpayers have spent
over 300 000
on each one of those children
so you kind of say well what's our
return on investment you got kids who
come out after 12th grade they can't
tell you the difference between a
congressman and a councilman they don't
know if they wanted to start a business
where they even begin
they're just too many things that we are
not aware of and one of the things i'm
deeply troubled by is the fact that you
look at a presidential election
only 56
of age eligible americans even vote in a
presidential election that's a little
more than half of our population
why is that why are people so apathy i
think that is because we don't prepare
young people through that k-12
experience
to be engaged citizens we hang that
slogan up in every school in america
um but that's not actually what we
practice
we we we practice kids getting ready to
take standardized exams that don't
necessarily have any real relevance to
what their lives really should be about
and that's what i have seen in that
space with boys i've seen it in that
space with boys and girls um if we don't
figure out ways to make their education
much more relevant to their day-to-day
lives um we will just be doing the
routine of going to school every day but
not necessarily preparing young people
what they need to be successful in their
future
and so as you engage and arguably a lot
of what you're saying applies to both
genders but as you as you engage in this
way you know what what are you seeing of
your graduates are they
are they being more successful in
college are they just more confident in
their their lives
what data points have you have you seen
so far
what we have seen is something that
sometimes is difficult to measure right
and so um
uh
how do you measure grit how do you
measure determination right that's
something that people have really been
been struggling with
um
every day at
eagle academy our young men recite the
poem invictus
and a victor says the is the poem of
resilience it was the poem recited by
nelson mandela every day when he was
locked up on robin's island for 27 years
it was the favorite poem of john lewis
who just recently passed away it's about
it's a poem that really talks about when
you get knocked down how to get back up
but we talk about that poem and we
recite that poem across with all 3 000
of our young men each and every day
and and that poem really represents
what we want from our young men to know
that life is going to hit you and you're
going to get knocked down but our young
men who've gone who graduated and gone
off to colleges and universities across
the country have been able to persevere
we've been able to get our numbers
graduation numbers higher than the
national average and we believe that's
because our young men may not come out
with the highest test scores but they
come out with something inside of them
which talks about how to stay focused
that when the going gets tough you got
to continue to fight and to press on and
that your destiny um is is is is
wonderful uh and full of potential and
that is that's what the whole eagle
experience has really represented for
them and that's what we continue to push
for with we're continuing listen we're
still very much a work in progress we're
still learning every day we're very much
a learning organization um but our young
men have been doing our young men have
been doing well and doing us proud
yeah no i could imagine and a lot of
great questions coming in from social
media from facebook
kids show ricardi is asking are there
strategies already in place to educate
the parents simultaneously to engage
them to nurture their kids and the
importance of their role in their kids
life while educating nurturing the kids
i believe that parents and teachers
equally play an important role in how we
shape their thoughts actions and
upbringing
thoughts
huge part of the work that we do at
eagle one of the reasons why we've been
as successful as we have been is because
we don't just talk about parents being
involved and engaged we practice that we
let our parents know we're we are
partners in this so let me give you one
example of something that we do that
most schools across america don't do
we gather our parents
for community gatherings with their
teachers and principals on saturday
mornings
now why is that important because the
traditional wednesday thursday night
after work meeting is something that
people have been doing all across
america we we lament the fact that lots
of parents don't come out and don't get
involved well they've got other kids
they've got two or three jobs it's
really tough and that's because we
generally set our schedule of how we
want parents to be involved we set that
in a space that benefits school p
personnel
it's good for us to show up on a
wednesday night we're already in school
we just stick around for a couple of
extra hours but we had an idea that if
we met parents on saturday mornings we
could get them much more involved and it
has been absolutely amazing the response
that we've gotten from our parents when
they show up on saturdays when we've
we've encouraged them to take the lead
and so it's not just the school
principal who has to run those meetings
but the parents themselves are leading
the work and the efforts and how you
engage the community it's a huge part of
the dna of what we do and uh and a real
big part of reason why we've been so
successful with our young men because
their parents have been running this
race side by side with us
now i love that idea but a lot of the
things we've already mentioned feel like
things that
many schools can replicate uh these
aren't like you know completely
re-engineering everything making sure
that kids feel supported believe in
themselves i love invictus i so i love
the fact that y'all are uh reciting that
or invoking that every day you know
having saturday uh meeting so it's much
more it's much easier for parents to
engage a lot of questions coming in
sure from youtube smart smartbear
asks uh david
what i guess you already talked a little
bit about this why you started eagle
academy but you know what are your
what are your inspirations i mean maybe
i'll broaden the question you know
describe this path you've talked about
spending three decades in education why
did you pick you know what were you like
in in high school and middle school
what brought you down this path and you
know at the end of your career what do
you hope you can look back on and say
happened
i i didn't go to school initially to
become an educator uh i started out as
an engineering major at rutgers
university and after a couple years i
switched to political science with the
intention of going to law school which i
ultimately did i started teaching and
having a family and uh and then went to
law school at night uh left education
never thinking that i was coming back
and and worked uh for the new york city
and new york state department of law
um but as fate would have it i was
really supposed to be working with young
people and i came back and became a
school administrator uh and and i've had
a wonderful career and am absolutely
living my purpose
so let me ask you one question on that
so you were you were a practicing lawyer
and then you somehow went to become a i
mean what was i mean you know i i
famously i was a tech guy hedge fund
analyst started tutoring cousins khan
academy how did you make that transition
from being a practicing lawyer to being
a school administrator
well uh it was because i i really as a
person of faith right i just i felt my
calling
was um well as a child i thought i
always wanted to be a lawyer
but but as as i got older i realized
that my real calling was working with
young people and so i decided to go to
go back into education and um and i went
back and i got my certification to be a
school administrator in in one semester
by going to three colleges at the same
time
um
which people have
found to be somewhat inspiring um but
for me was just an example that when
you're very focused on what it is that
you're supposed to be doing in life um
you know they say the universe will
conspire for your success
and uh and doors will open if you're
prepared to put in the work and i was
prepared to put in the work so for me on
a personal level uh that's kind of how i
got to be where i where i'm at kind of
being back in this education space but i
was inspired around this work of eagle
academy because columbia university put
out a report
that said that
uh 75
of the state's prison population
was coming from seven neighborhoods in
new york city so you think about that
sound right
um 75 if you look at the entire state of
new york 75 of the inmates were coming
not just from new york city but from
seven very specific zip codes in new
york city this is where people of color
are right central harlem the low east
side southeast queens um
you know uh uh bedford stuyvesant it's
the communities where where black folk
are
and and people knew it people were
writing books about it they were
analyzing data it was all kind of
research and white papers but at the end
of the day it seemed like the most you
could hope for was a good after-school
program for maybe 20 kids
and i said no we got to do more than
that that's the reason why we leaned
into creating eagle academy
not not that eagle would be the answer
as a cure-all but we certainly wanted it
to be a learning space for us a lab if
you will to figure out you know
how do we get these boys to believe in
themselves how do we get them to avoid
the lore of joining gangs and being on
street corners and for even for boys
that don't get caught up in that who
just never reached their potential
how do we get mentors into the lives of
young men right you recognize that
almost 70 percent of black boys in
america are growing up without without a
father at home
the hip-hop generation in many ways is a
fatherless generation
so boys become of age and they don't
have men to help them navigate the
transition from boyhood to manhood and
then when they get it wrong we blame
them as a society and so we said we
wanted to lean into that space to try to
figure out some answers
and uh and that's the just a journey
that we have been on but what we have
learned are lessons that we think are
good for boys
as well as for girls so i'll give you an
example
how can a boy dream of becoming an
investment banker if he's never met one
right you gotta you gotta open up
opportunities
to activate the power of possibility for
young people
if if if all you see is a very limited
number of things in your own
neighborhood or on your block it's hard
to even dream of doing great things
so how do you how do you bring an
astronaut in so folks get a chance to
meet him and help them to demystify what
does it take to become an astronaut or a
scientist or an investment banker or an
architect or a politician um these
things don't just happen that you've got
to be exposed and that's one of the
things we recognize with so many young
people particularly young people of
color who are not getting exposed
to the possibilities and that's where i
think
we have great opportunity now even in in
spite of this covet pandemic
what it has thrust us into is a space
where technology can actually be the
space that closes the gap
on so many of those opportunities where
you can use technology where you can
show young people what does it mean to
work at a wall street uh uh finance firm
or midtown law firm you don't
necessarily even have to always take the
trip there but you can
be exposed inside the walls and meet
with those kinds of career professionals
just like we're doing right now uh and
and young people are already um and i
think uh thank goodness so many of our
adults um because we've been zooming
every day have gotten uh much more
comfortable in this space think about
this as well sal and the implications in
our classrooms
if you have a school that doesn't have a
good math teacher now school the kids
are not getting good math results well
why should we be limited by simply that
math teacher that's right in front of us
every day
why can't you take the best math teacher
that you can find they may be in detroit
michigan but through technology why
can't that person teach those kids in
harlem
if you have the vision to do that we now
have the tools to close this this gap
in ways that we never had before
and and that's what i mean when i say
thinking out of the box
being much more uh imaginative around
the possibilities of what we can do
through the use of technology it can
help to transform the lives of so many
young people
and that kind of
you think about obviously the
circumstance we're in with distance
learning i am curious
you know there's obviously everyone's
been talking about the the pros and cons
mainly cons of distance learning but
you're also saying that there are some
silver linings and things like this how
are y'all navigating it and what do you
hope is lasting coming out of this
crisis
we've got something that we call a
virtual village uh where we have engaged
with our young people on a regular basis
even throughout this pandemic we're
getting ready to roll out something now
that we're calling a master class
where we're going to bring in experts
from all kinds of areas um but all of
our young people will have an
opportunity to be exposed to that they
would not normally get that exposure in
their day-to-day schooling experience
right so think about it so many young
people are interested in sports they're
interested in music they're interested
in the music industry but you get very
little exposure to that throughout
throughout the normal course of your
school day but what we're doing through
this master class series is is bringing
in people who are well versed in all
those areas who can come in and now just
share with these young people all of our
young people you know if you're
interested in getting into the music
industry here are the things that you
need to know um here these are the
skills that you need to have that's why
it's going to be important for you to
continue to pay to to do your homework
and stay very focused in your english
and your math classes because you're
going to need these kinds of skills what
if you want to become an investment
banker well first of all what does that
even mean um and so for young people to
hear from folks who can demystify that
process that's the space that we're
touching on now but we're getting ready
to blow that out in a major way
no that's incredible and that's
completely jails with what a lot of
we've been saying you know a lot of
people associate school as a place to
learn content standards and it is that
but it's also the place for
socialization place to be inspired place
to be supported and that's not often
explicitly stated in standards but
especially during distance learning it's
a lifeline for kids to a broader world
so that's really powerful what you're
doing a bunch of questions here
um
so uh smart bear
you answered this a little bit you know
why only boys i guess you know
smartbear's question like why not girls
is there kind of a corollary is there is
are there sister schools um that that
are addressing that or just maybe the
need it sounds like you were motivated
by some degree this you know
incarceration issue in a in a fairly
concentrated way which is
disproportionately boys uh are there
other elements you know folks who are
you know is there a benefit for uh girl
only schools is there something there
absolutely in fact in fact um
when we opened our doors in 2004 with
the very first eagle academy in the
bronx and i was the principal of the
school uh for several years earlier uh
there had been uh schools that had
already been opened up for girls um and
so our sister schools in many ways the
young women's leadership academies uh
they opened up about four or five years
before we did and they had already
opened up at least three schools um and
so in some in some ways
we balanced the the playing field um so
the question was being asked of them
well hey what about the boys and so
eagle academy came as a response and so
uh hillary clinton and claire mccaskill
and other senators at the time put forth
legislation that essentially allowed for
the proliferation of single gender
schools uh but but the caveat there was
that if you have a boys school they
ought to be a girls school doesn't have
to be started by the same organization
but the school district itself ought to
be putting in place a similarly situated
uh
uh for one as well as providing for the
other as well and that's what we've been
doing across uh wherever you see an
eagle academy you'll see a girls school
may not be not run by our organization
but but but that'll also that are also
in place
yeah no time always goes by
fast when we having an interesting
conversation one last question is um
you know longer term over the next few
years you know how do you see yourself
scaling how do you see you know is it is
the eagle academy a lab that other
people will replicate is there you know
at a higher level policy changes that
you think we can make to replicate some
of the work you're doing what do you
think is the 5-10 year path to getting
to getting more impact
yeah so we are as an organization we're
not going to be opening up more schools
per se certainly not more eagle
academies uh because we don't believe
that a brick and mortar approach is the
way to go but but really looking at
eagle in many ways is a lab so there are
school districts that want to open up an
all-boys school like ours um not an
eagle academy but something similar uh
and we have uh set ourselves up to help
to support schools uh districts like
that for what we call the eagle
institute so the institute is set up to
help to train school districts we help
los angeles open the first all boys
public school in their history called
the boys academic leadership academy
it's built on the eagle academy model
but i will tell you sal that the bigger
issue is that it's not single gender
schools no matter what you do they're
going to be a limited number of single
gender schools the bigger issue is what
have we learned in working with the boys
in this single gender model that will
help teachers in co-ed schools who
struggle every day with the boys and
that's where our work over the next 10
years is really going to be focused on
we've already started that in a number
of places where we're training the
educators in these school buildings and
in these districts and we're expanding
on that work now across the country to
help to teach them the most promising
practices around how do you get the most
out of the boys who are in your
classroom because across america it's
the boys and it's the boys of color who
are the ones who are at the bottom of
all the indicators of success so if you
can lift them um through the work and
the teachings and the things that we've
learned
you you you will be by definition be
lifting your entire school
um anyway and i will just leave you with
that one of the most important things is
about how you engage these young men in
relevant education if it's if the things
you're doing are just about doing the
routine of school because we're just
supposed to go and do our work that's
not going to get it done kids have got
to be engaged in things that they can
see outcomes in their own lives and in
their own communities and it can't
simply just be about we're preparing
kids to take standardized exams and then
if you do standardize exams well we said
it's a great school kids may not know
much about anything in life but we we
said it's a great school because they
did well on exams that that won't get it
done in working with the kind of
population that we're talking about
you've got to talk about real world
issues and how they can wrap their their
hearts and their minds and their work
around that and develop skills around
solving problems in their own
communities
no well david i this fascinating
conversation obviously we've met in many
contexts before but i look forward to uh
you know one see how we can help on this
journey and and learning from all the
incredible work that y'all are that
you've done and are likely to do in the
years ahead thank you for joining us
look forward to it thank you so much sam
well everyone uh thanks again for
joining our uh homeroom uh live stream
uh i look forward to seeing y'all i
think we're gonna go pick up next week
uh but uh as you can tell i'm never i
live my my life hour to hour
i need to look at the schedules a little
bit better but uh you know uh anyway
stay safe uh and keep learning and i'll
look forward to seeing you all on the
next live stream thanks everyone
you